شقي لا فيروس يعود بعد غياب يثير الرغبه
بين التونسيين فما القصه
هنا في مستشفى الاطفال في باب سعدون سجلت
تونس يوم الاربعاء الماضي اول حاله وفاه
بفيروس سيجالا لطفله تبلغ من العمر ثماني
سنوات اكدت مصادر رسميه انها توفيت اثرت
تدهور حالتها الصحيه بسبب معاناتها من
اعراض هذا الفيروس الذي بث حاله من الهلع
في العائله التونسيه
تعرفوا وجرثومه تشجيلها بانها بكتيريا
تصيب الجهاز الهضمي وتسبب الاسهال وتعتبر
من الامراض الخطيره التي تسبب الجفاف لدى
الاطفال ومضاعفات صحيه خطيره قد تؤدي الى
الوفاه كانت منتشره في ثمانينات وتسعينات
القرن الماضي قبل ان تختفي من تونس
[موسيقى]
شقي لا تعود من جديد وزاره الصحه تحذر من
انها شديده المقاومه وتيته طفله الثماني
سنوات كسرت الاعتقاد السائده بان هذه
الجرثومه خطيره فقط عم لا يتجاوز عمرهم
خمس سنوات فهل ياخذ فيروس
هنا الى صباح العربيه احلى من عبد الله
تونس